[Musique]
on n'est pas bien là comments ensemble
pourra pas signer l'armistice nhk
enfin charlotte elle s'est enfermée dans
cette histoire d'amour et comme mc
sélect comme ça du coup plus personne ne
veut les voir et je suis la bande est
coupée en deux donc voilà comment est ce
que j'ai tenté des amis de chez sa femme
où j'ai battu dans l'eau bien
[Musique]
d'accord moi maire du 9e et wade enfin
moi je suis quand même
fatigué
[Musique]
dire aux autres que c'est moi qui te
larguer bien parce que tu m'épates
arrive à tomber enceinte un tu me voler
ma vie en fait on attends tu parles de
quoi là je parle de ça
[Musique]
voix sont plus mais ça vaut même jamais
je t'aime encore plus mal
et on allait voir un enfant je te
promets c'est toi et tu sais moi pour ce
que tu ressens
lançons les meufs elle aime les hommes
vulnérables
elle aime les hommes qui se remettent en
question
le conquet pour medal de foncer et foncé
qui on savait goodman alpha de merde la
femme a toujours été de l'homme le plus
fidèle compagnon
ça c'est le chien
clown en chine + thème
pardonner c'est grandir
notre faute
on va fêter ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]